in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some urban developers get
their sensor straight will we be able to
find parking in time stay tuned to find
out
like most IOT companies urban IOT makes
their money deploying hordes of sensors
in an urban area that monitor everything
from noise temperature and humidity
which of course means the majority of
their data that they collect from those
devices consists of time stamps and
simple floating-point numbers the volume
of which quickly started showing a
problem with data store performance see
cloud datastore is built on top of
BigTable and thus is subject to its
performance characteristics BigTable
scales by sharding rows into separate
tablets which are basically a contiguous
unit of storage and when a tablet
experiences a high write rate the tablet
will split allowing it to scale even
further the important point here is this
rows any tablet are ordered such that it
helps distribute the workload amongst
multiple tablets they do this by sorting
the rows like so graphically by their
key and as long as the keys are randomly
distributed this sorting works pretty
fun however if your keys are Alexa
graphically close then your performance
starts to suffer as your operations can
be isolated into a small update window
which lo and behold was exactly what
urban IOT was doing turns out they're
Federation of IOT devices were pushing
sensor readings into datastore and using
the time stamp as the key for the entity
so they could easily fetch and display
the results later time stamps of course
are a monotonically increasing value
which is being used as an indexed
property which led right into the hop
spotting scenario that we were worried
about now here's the really interesting
part this behavior was really hard to
repo on our side I mean we set up a 250
QPS load test creating entities with
keys that are time stamps over a 20
minute window and didn't see anything
datastore did an amazing job at
absorbing that level of work no problems
whatsoever in order to actually see this
behavior we had to jack the QPS up to
750 and let the test run for over an
hour you can see that over time it takes
a little longer to handle the same
operations for urban IOT the least
invasive fix for this problem was
penned a random prefix to their time
stamps which caused some headaches in
their dashboard for fetching but also
allowed their performance to land back
in the non hot spotted area now I just
want to highlight something again this
is not a standard run-of-the-mill
performance issue it took a couple of
days of really hammering on datastore to
get our test to behave the way that
urban IOT was seeing in the wild and my
guess is that unless your use case is
very similar to theirs chances are you
won't run into it so if you'd like ideas
on where to spend your time instead make
sure you check out the rest of the cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts